[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
[موسيقى]
دعم كل ما من شانه الاسهام في خفض حبه
التوتر والتصعيد والوصول وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه يؤكدوا حرص الرياض على تخفيف
معاناه اليمنيين ودعمها للسلام
طفل الاوكراني وتؤكد انها ترعى اسرا فرت
من الحرب ومرضى وايتاما
اجتماع العقبه ينتهي بتوافق على حوار
فلسطيني اسرائيلي مباشر والتزام بتعليق
الخطوات الاحاديه
لدينا ايضا
تحت شعار التضامن وزير الخارجيه المصريه
الى سوريا وتركيا غدا لعرض المساعده بعد
كارثه الزلزال
[موسيقى]
التقى الرئيس الاوكراني فرض بوزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
في كييف واكد الامير فيصل بن فرحان
ليزيلنسكي ان المملكه تبذل كل الجهود
لتخفيف معاناه الشعب الاوكراني وقال ان
المملكه قدمت حزمتين من المساعدات
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 410 ملايين دولار
وشكر الرئيس الاوكراني المملكه بدوره على
دعمها جهود السلام
في هذا الاطار اؤكد ان اهتمام السيد خالد
بن الحرمين الشريفين واسمه العهد في
الجانب الانساني في اوكرانيا كبير جدا وقد
اتى نتيجه ذلك توجيه القياده بتقديم
حزبتين من المساعدات الانسانيه لاوكرانيا
بمبلغ اجمالي 410 مليون دولار وقد وقعنا
اليوم على اتفاقتين
تؤسس لتسليم هذه
الاعانات ونامل ان تكون
عونا في تخفيف معاناه الشعب الاوكراني في
هذه الازمه الانسانيه ولا شك ان المملكه
تبذل كافه الجهود التي من شانها التخفيف
من معاناه الشعب الاوكراني في الداخل
والنازحين في دول الجوار
كما اكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان حرصه المملكه على حل الازمه
في اوكرانيا بالحوار وشدد على ضروره خفض
التصعيد وحمايه المدنيين
المملكه حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه الاسهام في خفض حده
التوتر والتصعيد والوصول الى حل سلمي لهذه
الحرب ونحن السعوديه لان الذين قناع راسخه
ان اي نهايه للحرب يجب ان يكون بالحوار
على طاوله في اطار مبادئ القانون الدولي
وميثاق للامم المتحده واحترام سياده الدول
ولهذا سوف نستمر في العمل مع جميع الاطراف
للبحث عن فرص الوصول الى هكذا تسويه
كما وجر استعراض جهود المملكه الراميه الى
ايجاد حلول سياسيه للازمه الاوكرانيه
ووقعت السعوديه مع اوكرانيا مذكره تفاهم
للمشتقات النفطيه وبرنامجا للعمل الانساني
واعلن الصندوق السعودي للتنميه عن دعم
اوكرانيا بالغاز المسال ومشتقات النفط
بمبلغ 300 مليون دولار
وقعنا للتو وثيقتين تضعان الاساس لتطوير
التعاون احداهما داخل وزاره اعاده الاعمار
والاخرى داخل وزاره الطاقه وهذا يعني ان
المجالات محدده والتوجهات ستكون جديده
وقويه سيتم وضع الخطوط العريضه للمشاريع
المقبله
معنا من كيف مفرد العربيه الى هناك احمد
اهلا بك احمد يعني لابد وان هناك الكثير
من الاصداء الايجابيه وردود الفعل على هذه
الزياره بما حققته على الصعيدين السياسي
والمادي كذلك ما ابرز ردود الفعل هذه
نعم طاهر يعني كان لقاء وديا ومثمرا هكذا
علقت القياده السياسيه هنا في اوكرانيا
على اللقاء الذي جمع بين الرئيس الاوكراني
ووزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان اللقاء الذي عقد عصر هذا اليوم يعني
سبقه لقاء مع رئيس المكتب
مكتب الرئيس زينسكي تم تقديم حزمتين من
المساعدات بقيمه 410 مليون دولار
300 مليون دولار من صندوق التنميه السعودي
كمشتقات نفطيه وغاز مسال ومئه مليون دولار
من مركز المالي للاغاثه هذه ليست
المنحه الاولى المركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
كان هناك ايضا مساعدات بقيمه 10 مليون
دولار قبل اشهر للاجئين الاوكران الذين
فروا من اوكرانيا بعد بدايه هذه الحرب كان
هناك ايضا مؤتمرا صحفيا تحدث فيه كل من
وزير خارجيه السعوديه وزير خارجيه
الاوكرانيه وال مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
انتريه والذي اكد ان السعوديه لها جهود
كبيره خلال الفتره الماضيه خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالافراج عن عشره من اسرى الحرب
الاوكران هذه هذا الافراج كان للسعوديه
دور كبير في كذلك ايضا المبادرات التي
تسعى لحل الازمات التي اصابت الدول
الكثير من الدول بهذه الحرب منها مبادرات
حبوب من اوكرانيا والتي يعني ارادت بها
اوكرانيا تسهيل توصيل الحبوب الى الدول
المختلفه كانت السعوديه ايضا دور كبير في
ذلك كما قال رئيس المكتب رئيس مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني كذلك ايضا هناك حديث عن ان يكون
هناك مشاركه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه في
سبل والمفاوضات التي من الممكن ان تجي
خلال فتره المقبله خاصه وان
السعوديه قالت انها تدعم وترى ان
المفاوضات والحل السلمي هو الحل الوحيد
لانهاء هذا
الصراع في اطار القانون الدوليه وميثاق
الامم المتحده واحترام سياده الدول نقطه
ايضا هامه اشار اليها
المتحدثون في او المتحدث الاوكراني في
المؤتمر الصحفي قال ان هناك ايضا يعني
عواقب او مخاطر مشتركه تجمع بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه واوكرانيا منها الطائرات
الايرانيه المسيره التي زودت بها ايران
روسيا وتستهدف بها الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وتسفر عن قتل عدد كبير من الافراد وكذلك
تدمير البنيه التحتيه هذه الطائرات ذاتها
تزود بها ايران المتمردين الحوثيين
وتستهدف بها المنشات النفطيه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هناك تقدير كبير من قبل
القياده السياسيه هنا في اوكرانيا للدعم
السياسي والاقتصادي والانساني الذي تقدمه
مملكه العربيه السعوديه
لاوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات احمد باقات ومفرد العربيه الى
كيف تحياتنا اليك
[موسيقى]
وفي مقابله خاصه بالعربيه اعرب حاكم
لوجانسك عن امله بوصوله الاسلحه الغربيه
لشن هجوم مباغت على الروس وتحرير المنطقه
في المقابل قال وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه
ان المدى الذي ستضطر معه روسيا الى الدفاع
عن حدودها ستحدده شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه
الى اوكرانيا كما شدد على عدم التراجع عن
تنفيذ اهداف العمليه العسكريه لحمايه حدود
البلاد من اي تهديدات
هذا وقد سخر
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي من
التقارير الغربيه عن نقص المحتمل بالاسلحه
والذخيره الروسيه واكادمت ان المصانع في
روسيا عززت انتاجها بنحو عشره اضعاف
وباستخدام تقنيات غربيه حديثه تم
الاستيلاء عليها في ساحه المعركه اوضح ان
المهندسين الروس يستفيدون من تفكيك هذه
الاسلحه واصفا ذلك بتحويل تجربه العدو
لمصلحتهم وفق تعبيره
قال متحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه ان
المناقشات بخصوص تقديم حلف النيتو ضمانات
امنيه محتمله لاوكرانيا لم تشهد تقدما منذ
شهور ياتي هذا الاعلان عقب تقرير لوسط
جورنال افادا بان بعض اكبر اعضاء حلف
الناتو اقترحوا توقيع معاهده الدفاع مع
اوكرانيا
لوقف اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا وقال ان طرح
خطط السلام الصينيه بالتزامن مع التقارير
بان التبكين تخطط لامداد روسيا بالطائرات
المسيره الانتحاريه يؤكد على ضروره الحكم
على موقف الصين بافعالها لا باقوالها
كان مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي قال انه
اذا قررت بكين دعم موسكو فانها ستدفع ثمنا
باهظا واضاف سولفا مع عواقب دعم روسيا
واضحه امام الصين لكنه اشار في الوقت ذاته
الى ان الصين لم تتخذ اي خطوه لدعم روسيا
ولم يتم رصد اشارات على ذلك
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا طالت تبعاتها
مختلف فئات الشعب الاوكراني ولعل اكثر
المتضررين هم الفئه الاضعف الاطفال تقرير
امريكي صادر عن مركز يايل للابحاث تحدث عن
ان روسيا تحتجز اكثر من سته الاف طفل
اوكراني فيما قد يرقى الى جريمه حرب بحسب
المركز البحث قال ان احتجاز الاطفال
الاوكرانيين في روسيا يهدف الى اعاده
تثقيفهم وتشكيلهم وفق اهداف وغايات روسيه
مركز الابحاث اشار الى انه منذ بدء الحرب
قبل عام يتم نقل اطفال لا تتجاوز اعمار
بعضهم اربعه اشهر الى 43 معسكر في انحاء
روسيا من اجل التعليم الوطني والتثقيف
العسكري والمتعلق بالجيش الروسي العربيه
التقت الباحث في المركز وهو النيثنيل
ريموند المدير التنفيذي لمختبر البحوث
الانسانيه بجامعه ييل الذي تو ان يكون رقم
الاطفال المخطوفين اكبر من المذكور
والمتوقع حتى الان
لدينا عدد كبير من المواقع قيد البحث الان
نحن نحقق فيما يقرب من 43 موقعا ونشعر
بثقه كبيره بان عدد الاطفال المخطوفين
اعلى بشكل كبير بالاضافه لذلك نعتقد ان
الرقم سته الاف الذي ذكرناه يضاف اليه
15,000 اعلنت الحكومه الاوكرانيه واعتقد
ان الرقم سيزداد في الايام والاسابيع
المقبله
رايمان اضاف ان روسيا تنتهك بشكل واضح
اتفاقيه جنائذ الرابعه حول معامله
المدنيين خلال الحرب وقال ان تقرير المركز
اشبه بجرس انذار حيال الوضع المتعلق بخطف
الاطفال الاوكرانيين
ما ساقوله لروسيا هو اقراوا اتفاقيه جنيف
التي انتم طرف فيها تحضر الاتفاقيه
الرابعه صراحه نقل الاطفال الى بلد يعتبر
طرفا في نزاع ببلد اخر وينص على نقلهم الى
دوله او طرف ثالث بالاضافه الى ذلك انت
بحاجه لتسجيل الاطفال والسماح لهم
بالاتصال بدويهم والسماح للمراقبين
الدوليين بزيارتهم في الوقت الحالي بغض
النظر عن الدور الانساني الذي تقول روسيا
انها تؤديه الا انها لم تلتزم بالقانون
خلال هذه الفتره
تقرير مركز يائل للابحاث طالب بهيئه
محايده يسمح لها بالوصول الى المعسكرات
الروسيه وبان توقف روسيا على الفور
اجراءات تبني اطفال اوكرانيين وفصل الباحث
في المركز نيثاني في مقابله مع العربيه
المناطق التي يتم منها اختطاف الاطفال
الاوكرانيين نتابع جزءا اخر من هذه
المقابله مع طلال الحاج
المجموعه رقم واحد هم بالدرجه الاولى من
دونسك ويشكلون الاغلبيه هم من الاطفال
الذين يكونوا ابائهم في كثير من الاحيان
موظفين محليين ويقال لهم ان بالامكان ان
لا يرسلوا ابنائهم للقتال وبدلا من ذلك
يرسلون الى معسكرات لا يعودون منها
المجموعه الثانيه يطلب الروس اجلائهم
وتحديدا من خاركيب والزابوريجيا وماريوبول
وخيرسون وكل هؤلاء الاطفال كانوا في
مؤسسات الدوله الاوكرانيه في فتره ما قبل
الغزواني وفي المقابله ايضا دعا مركز جياي
الابحاث الى ان تفرض مختلف الدول عقوبات
على الجهات الروسيه المتورطه في احتجاز او
اختطاف الاطفال الاوكرانيين
والقيام بارسالهم الى روسيا
يتبنى عقوبات ضد الافراد المتورطين في هذا
البرنامج الروسي واعتقد انه من المحتمل ان
تتخذ دول اخرى مسارا مشابها وهو ما امله
نرى ايضا ضغطا لايجاد نظام تسجيل دولي
موحد لهؤلاء الاطفال واعتقد انه يجب ان
تسال كل دوله عضو في الامم المتحده ما
الذي تفعله للتاكد من محاسبه اولئك الذين
يشاركون في سلسله القياده الروسيه ويجب ان
نضمن قدرتنا على احصاء هؤلاء الاطفال
ومعرفه كيفيه التعامل مع هذا العدد الكبير
نهايه الاسبوع الماضي عقد مجلس الامن
الدوليه جلسه في الذكرى الاولى لحرب
اوكرانيا ومن بين الملفات التي كانت
مطروحه موضوع الاطفال المختطفين من
اوكرانيا واولئك المرحلين الى روسيا
خلال العام المنصرم قتلت روسيا عشرات
الالاف من الاوكرانيين من نساء ورجال
واطفال واقتلعت اكثر من 13 مليون شخص من
ديارهم ودمرت اكثر من نصف شبكه الطاقه
الاوكرانيه او قصفت اكثر من 700 مستشفى
واختطفت على الاقل سته الاف من الاطفال
الاوكرانيين وقامت بترحيلهم الى روسيا
روسيا تنفذ الان في اوكرانيا على الارجح
اكبر عمليه اختطاف اطفال تدار برعايه دوله
في التاريخ الحديث
هؤلاء الاطفال يجب اعادتهم الى العائلات
او الاوصيع القانونيين دون تاخير وسيظل
الاثر الماساوي لعمليات النقل والترحيل
هذه على الاطفال الاوكرانيين للاجيال
القادمه
روسيا ردت على التقارير التي تحدثت عن
احتجازها اطفالا اوكرانيين عبر بيان
لسفارتها في واشنطن البيان قال ان روسيا
استقبلت اطفالا اجبروا على الفرار مع
اسرهم من القصف في اوكرانيا واضافت
السفاره ان روسيا تبذل قصار جهدها للحفاظ
على القصر مع اسرهم وفي حالات غياب او
وفاه الوالدين والاقارب يوضع الايتام تحت
وصايه
واعتبرت روسيا اجراءاتها بمثابه انقاذ
ايتام او نقل الاطفال لرعايه طبيه قبل ذلك
كشف التقارير غربيه عن ان مساعدين للرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين انخرطوا عن كثب في
عمليه نقل الاطفال الاوكرانيين الى عوائل
روسيه خصوصا ماريال فوفا بيلوفا المفوضه
الرئاسيه لحقوق الطفل وقد ظهرت المسؤوله
الروسيه في مقاطع مصوره في اكتوبر الماضي
وهي تنزل من طائره عسكريه برفقه ثلاثه
وخمسين طفلا اوكرانيا قالت حينها انهم
ايتام تم انقاذهم من مناطق الحرب في
دومباس شرق اوكرانيا وان رئيس اقليم
دانياسك الموالي لروسيا طلب اجلاء الاطفال
الى مناطق امنه انذاك اعلن الكرملين ان
هؤلاء الاطفال سينضمون الى 300 وخمسين
طفلا اخرين تم تبنيهم ليبداوا حياه جديده
في روسيا وبشكل عام تختلف التقديرات حول
اعداد الاطفال الاوكرانيين الذين نقلتهم
روسيا الى مناطقها والارقام تتراوح بين
سته الاف طفل وعشرات الالاف منهم اذا ما
اخذ بعين الاعتبار نشاط روسيا ووكلائها في
المناطق التي يسيطرون عليها في الشرق
الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
معنى من موسكو وسفيره
دبلوماسي السابق اهلا بك معنا سعد سفير
كيف تردون على هذا الكلام
سعد سفير معي تسمعني
من اين حصلتم على هذه المعلومات
قلنا من اين حصلنا عليها كانت هذه مقابله
مطوله اولا لاحد الباحثين الكبار من جامعه
ايل وهو نيثني ريموند واجرى معه مقابله
مطوله زميلنا طلال الحاج كبير مراسلينا في
نيويورك في الامم المتحده
اضافه الى كل ما تقدم ذكرنا ان في الروسي
الذي تعاطى مع مثل هذه الاخبار اذا هي
اخبار معروفه تفضل
لا توجد لدي هذه المعلومات وكل
وهذه المعلومات التي تتحدثون عنها غير
موثوقه
وكل جل ما ذكر لا يمكن الوثوق به
اذا ما كان لك ان تطرح علي اسئله جاده غير
هذا الموضوع فانا مستعد لمناقشه اسئله
جاده وليس فقط مجرد احاديث تم اجراءه هنا
وهناك غير موثوقه اولا هذه جلسه لمجلس
الامن الدولي ذكر فيها الموضوع ثانيا هذه
جامعه ياي الاحدى اعرق جامعات العالم
ثالثا هناك مقابله مصوره عرضنا مقاطع منها
مع زميل طلال الحاج
رابعا هناك رد روسي عرضناه عبر بيان سفاره
الروسيه في واشنطن واللي تحدث عن هذا
الموضوع وضعه في سياق اخر وهو سياق انقاذ
الايتام ويعني نحن ايضا مصرون على تبيان
الموقف الروسي مقابل كل المعلومات التي
استندنا اليها من الجانب الاخر ولذلك
ساعدتك معنا ضيف في هذا البرنامج لكي
تتحدث عن وجهه النظر الروسيه الرسميه او
وفق ما تمتلكه من معلومات حول هذا الموضوع
نعطيك المجال لتفعل ذلك ساعات السفير
في الواقع الامر هذه المعلومات
غير موثوقه وما اعلمه باننا
نقوم بانقاذ الالاف من الاطفال الذين
باتوا ضحايا لقصف الاوكرانيه والمدفعيه
الاوكرانيه التي كانت امعنت في قصفها
لاكثر من ثمان سنوات في كل صباح ومساء
وتقوم بقصف هذه المناطق في اقليم دومباس
الناس يموتون طوال هذه السنوات لذا فكان
لزاما علينا ان نقوم بانقاذ السكان بما في
ذلك الاطفال في اقليم الدومباس للقدوم الى
مدننا ومن اجل
ان يكونوا جزءا من الاتحاد الروسي هذا
معلم هؤلاء
هذه انشطه اجراميه من قبل الجانب
الاوكراني
وتؤيده الروايه الاوروبيه الان
في الصحافه انهم يسعون لايجاد روايات
مختلفه عن الحقيقه هذه قضيه ملحه حول
السكان الذين يعيشون في الدومباس ويعانون
منذ سنوات طويله اكثر من ثمان سنوات بما
في ذلك الاطفال لذا فنحن نحضرهم ونقدم لهم
المساعده قدر الامكان ولماذا تشمل هذه
المساعده التعليم الوطني والتثقيف العسكري
المتعلق بالجيش الروسي لاطفال ليس لهم
قرار من المفترض انهم اوكرانيون ولكن فجاه
اصبحوا في روسيا دون ان يقرروا دون ان
يكونوا في عمر يقررون فيه اذا هذا بالنسبه
الى نفس المقابله ونفس المصدر انتهاك
الاتفاقيه جنيف الرابعه حول معامله
المدنيين ثم لماذا ينقلون اصلا الى داخل
الروسي لماذا لا يبقون في المناطق التي
ضميتموها مثلا
لا اعلم اذا ما كانت حقيقه هذه المعلومات
التي تتحدث عنها يمكن الوثوق بها فمن
الغريب بانك تخاطبني كما لو انني متخصص في
هذه القضيه
ويبدو
بان المساله غير صحيحه اذا كنت مستعدا
للتحدث في موضوع جدي فلنفعل ذلك وان لم
يكن ذلك هذا موضوع جدي جدا بالنسبه الينا
وبالنسبه الى العالم اجمع واعتقد انه
جازما انه جدي جدا بالنسبه الى الروس كل
الشعب الروسي وانا متاكد انه موضوع
الاطفال وموضوع مستقبل الاجيال جدي لكل
الناس وامل ان تعتبره جديا كذلك لانه
بالفعل كذلك وارجو ان تبقى معنا لكي انتقل
الى نقطه اخرى متعلقه بالموضوع ولكن فيها
بعض التفاصيل حول الديموغرافيا الروسيه لو
تكرمت سعد السفير
اذا فتح ملف الاطفال الاوكرانيين في الوقت
الذي تعاني فيه روسيا من قنبله ديموغرافيه
زمنيه ستجعل من الصعب عليها ان تشن حربا
في المستقبل او المحافظه على استمرار
اقتصادها المتعثر تختلف التقديرات لاعداد
القتلى الروس في اوكرانيا وسواء كان عشره
الاف كما يقول الروس او مئه الف كما يقول
الاوكرانيون فان الرقم لا يبدو كبيرا في
بلد تعداده 145 مليون نسمه لكن الخبراء
يحذرون هنا من ان ارسال الشباب الى ساحه
المعركه بالاضافه الى الهجره سيؤديان
لانخفاض عدد المواليد بعشرات الالاف وقد
شهدت روسيا موجات فيرار جماعيه لشبابها
الموهوبين وحتى النساء الروسيات سافرنا
للخارج للولاده ونيل جنسيه اخرى ولذا تذهب
التقديرات الى ان روسيا قد تشهد اقل من
مليون فاصل اثنين ولاده هذا العام يعني من
مليون و200 الف ولاده اذا استمرت العمليات
العسكريه في الاشهر المقبله وهو الحد
الادنى في التاريخ الحديث قسم اخر يذهب
للقول ان روسيا حتى لو كانت خسرت 800 الف
مهاجر للخارج بسبب الحرب لكنها في المقابل
كسبت حوالى مليون اوكراني من المناطق التي
ضمتها الحقيقه ان البنيه العمريه
والتعليميه لاولئك الذين هاجروا منها
والذين هاجروا اليها مختلفه تماما ولا
تصبوا في صالح موسكو
نعود الى موسكو وسفير
دبلوماسي السابق اهلا بك معنا سعاده
السفير نحدثك هنا عن هذه الجزئيه تحديدا
وارجو ان تكون جديه كفايه لكي ترد عليها
هل روسيا امام ازمه ديموغرافيه حقيقيه
تحاول التعويض بسببها من هنا وهناك
بسياسات واجراءات مختلفه
نعم من الصحيح ان بعض الناس
يتحدثون عن هذا التراجع
الديموغرافيك وكان هناك خلال سنوات الثلاث
الماضيه اعداد كبيره من المواطنين
الاوكرانيين الذين جاءوا من تلقائي انفسهم
الى الى من اوكرانيا الى روسيا ونعلم ان
هذه الاعداد هي وان اعداد القادمين اكثر
من الذين خرجوا بالاضافه الى ذلك
اعتقد باننا اتخذنا قرارات
بان سكان
هذه المناطق التي كانت سابقه اوكرانيا
وتنتمي الينا في الاتحاد الروسي بان كافه
الاسر التي
باتت هناك لديها افراد يصل عددهم الى
ثلاثه اشخاص ويتم تزويدهم بالمعونات
والدعم
بحيث يستطيعون بناء اسر كبيره
اعتقد باننا نعمل على زياده عدد السكان
قد يكون الهدف صعبا كما هو الحال بالنسبه
لمناطق اخرى لكن اذا كنت تتعلق عن مجموعه
عن اجمالي عدد السكان فهذا فهناك خروج
كبير من المناطق الاوكرانيه فهم ياتون
الينا كلاجئين
وبحثا عن ماوى اذ يجدون فرصا مئاتيه في
مدننا وبلداننا وهذه
وهذا يدفعنا لتقديم الاموال
لرعايه هؤلاء الوافدين الجدد
وخاصه اننا نتحدث عن عن المئات من الاف
الاشخاص الذين ياتون الى مناطق الاتحاد
الروسي
طيب ولكن ما ذكرناه بناء على اخر
المعلومات وارجو ان يكون يعني صدرك رحبا
كفايه لكي تتقبل ذلك سعه السفير انه في
موجات فرار جماعي لشباب الموهوبين بمعنى
ان روسيا ليست ارضا او بيئه خصبه لكي تحوي
هؤلاء ولكي تبقيهم في الداخل مقابل ايضا
العديد من النساء الروسيات اللائي يسافرنا
الى الخارج لنيل جنسيه اخرى
اضافه الى عدم نجاح سياسه زياده النسل
التي اعتمدتها الرئاسه الروسيه في السابق
لابد وانه لذلك سبب
وهو عدم رؤيه الامل الكافي لهؤلاء الناس
لكي يظلوا في الداخل ولكي يتناسلوا وتعيش
اجيالهم اللاحقه بعد ذلك في روسيا لعده
اسباب منها سياسيه منها اجتماعيه ومنها
اقتصاديه ما رايك
ان المعلومات التي تستخدمونها اليوم هي
معلومات غريبه حقا
وهي تلك المعلومات
التي يتم سماعها من جانب واحدا من القصه
وليس من طرفين
هذه الظاهره كما تعلمون تحدث في دول كثيره
ونحن لدينا ارقام كامله عن الاشخاص الذين
يخرجون من البلاد وهي ليست بارقام كبيره
بالمقارنه لعدد المواطنين الاجماليين ولا
يشكل هذا الامر خطرا كبيرا على سكاننا في
الاتحاد الروسي وهؤلاء الاشخاص يذهبون او
البعض منهم
يتجهون من تلقائي انفسهم ونحن لا نضع اي
عثرات امامهم اذا ما قرروا ذلك الخير في
اي شخص يرغب بمغادره البلاد بصوره طوعيه
فله حق ذلك هذا خيارهم اما فيما يتعلق
الحجم فهذا ليس مرعبا او مخيفا
والمقاربه
التي طرحتها في سؤالك اليوم تعد غريبه
للغايه
ولا تؤذن بواقع الحاله الفعلي هنا
تمام على الاقل انه عرضنا كل وجهات النظر
حول هذا الموضوع معكم ساعات السفير ونحن
قلنا في العرض الاخباري في العرضين
السابقين عن كل مصادرنا وكان ذلك بعض كان
بعض ذلك بالصوت والصوره وان لم يكن بالصوت
والصوره قلنا ما المصدر ومن الذي قال وكنت
ضيفا عزيزا علينا لكي تخبرنا بوجهه النظر
الروسيه وهذا ما حصل يعني المعلومات ليست
غريبه علينا لاننا نعرف مصادرها واذعناها
تماما ووجهه نظرك كمان وبالمطول وليس
بالمقابلات القصيره التي اعتدنا عليها
حفاظا على وجهات النظر الاخرى شكرا جزيلا
سعاده السفير
الديبلوماسي السابق من موسكو تحياتي اليك
في العربيه 360 ايضا
انهيار جديد للتومان الايرانيه امام
الدولار والانتقادات للحكومه تعلو تحت قبه
البرلمان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نتابع واياكم في العربيه
360 مستويات قياسيه للدولار في السوق
الايرانيه ولا مؤشرات لعوده الهدوء فقد
تجاوز سعر الدولار حاجز 60 الف تومان
ليسجل زياده منذ منتصف فبراير باكثر من
ثلاثين بالمئه في مقابل التومان كل هذه
التطورات تاتي رغم انشاء الحكومه مركزا من
اجل تبادل العملات والذهب لاداره سوق
الصرف الاجنبي خاصه بعد تقلص تعاملات
ايران مع العراق بضغط من الولايات المتحده
عقب اكتشاف تهريب ملايين الدولارات من
البنوك العراقيه الى طهران اخطر ما في
الموضوع ان علي رضا ممثل تبريز في
البرلمان نقل عن محمد مخبر النائب الاول
للرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي قوله انه ليس لدى
النظام حل افضل اداره سوق العملات قالها
بوضوح هذا كل ما لدينا دفعت هذه المواقف
عددا من النواب الى شن هجوم حاد على
الفريق الاقتصادي في حكومه ابراهيم رئيسي
هذا
[موسيقى]
النطق غبي
مدينه اقتصاد كافينيشات
فقير محترم الجهودك
شام مهبرينج دردشه
وفق تقرير لمركز الاحصاء الايراني فان
معدل التضخم في فبراير الحالي بلغ ثلاثه
وخمسين بالمئه واربعه اعشار النقطه
المئويه بزياده اثنين فاصل واحد بالمئه
مقارنه بالشهر السابق وبسبب هذا التضخم
الكبير تحولت انظار الايرانيين للبحث عن
ملاذات امنه تحفظ مدخراتهم وهذا ما ينذر
بمزيد من الصعوبات التي تنتظر التومان
معنى من لندن الباحث في الشان الايراني
عارف نصر اهلا بك معنا استاذ عارف لو نرصد
معك ابرز الاسباب التي اوصلت الامور الى
هنا الى 60 الف تومان للدولار
تحيه طيبه لك استاذ طاهر والمشاهدين
العربيه الكرام الواقع هنالك عده نقاط
مهمه ربما اشرتم الى بعضها اهمها بان اولا
الاقتصاد الايراني يعاني من ازمه بنيويه
ويعاني من مسلسل من العقوبات اثا يعني
جعله هشا ويتاثر
بالاحداث السياسيه والاجتماعيه والمظاهرات
والاحتجاجات التي تحدث بشكل اكبر وبالتالي
الحكومه ما هي الا تعمل كرجل اطفال لا
تستطيع ان تحرك اي ساكن النقطه الثانيه
واعتقد انها مهمه هي ربما السياسات التي
اتخذتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
العراق وكذلك ببعض دول الخليج وحتى في
افغانستان
جعل من عمليه تبادل الدولار صعب جدا
النقطه الثالثه نحن في شهر اسفند وهو اخر
شهر
ايراني يعني اقل من 20 يوم سوف تكون السنه
القادمه وعاده ما تكون هنالك تغلبات
اقتصاديه كبيره والنقطه الرابعه اعتقد
تكمن بان فريق رئيسي الاقتصادي هو يمثل لا
يمثل
مصالح الحكومه بل يمثل الحرس الثوري وكذلك
الفريق الاقتصادي لخامنه معظم هؤلاء سواء
وزير التجاره او كذلك
وزير الاقتصاد وباقي الوزارات هم بالاساس
جاءوا من مؤسسات تابعه الى المرشد
الايراني مباشره اعتقد ان هذه العوامل هي
التي
واوصلت البلاد الى ما هي عليه طبعا كما
قلنا قبل قليل انه احد
ممثلي البرلمان الشعب في البرلمان نقل عن
النائب الاول للرئيس قوله انه هذا كل ما
لدينا هل استنفذت طهران كل
الامكانيات التي لديها لكي ينقذ الوضع
ومذا لو لم تفعل في الاشهر المقبله ماذا
سيحصل
يعني انا اعتقد بان هذا
كل
سياساتها
النظام الايراني بل الحكومه تعمل احيانا
هي تدفع بزياده لسعر الدولار او هبوط لسعر
الريال حتى تدعم ميزانيتها وهذا ما كان
يفعله قبل ابراهيم رئيسي روحاني وكذلك حتى
احمد نجاه لذلك انا اعتقد بان احدى
السياسات الحكومه هي التلاعب باسعار
العمله لكنما النقطه الثانيه التي ربما
ممكن ان نقراها بتصريح محمد مخبر هو ان
الحكومه لا تجد نفسها بانها بحاجه الى ان
تفسر
مواقفها الى الشعب ولا تعتبر نفسها مسؤوله
امام الشعب وهذه السياسه التي ينتهجها قبل
الحكومه المرشد الايراني
باتت ليست فقط بالجانب السياسي بل تطبق
حتى على الجانب الاقتصادي شكرا جزيلا لك
استاذ عارف ناصر البحث في الايراني من
لندن تحياتنا اليك
[موسيقى]
من اجتماعي
قال مستشار الامن القومي للبيت الابيض ان
الولايات المتحده ترحب بالتعهدات التي
قطعتها اسرائيل والسلطه الفلسطينيه بشان
وقف التصعيد ومنع المزيد من العنف
ان اجتماع العقبه نقطه انطلاق ايجابيه
وهناك الكثير من العمل الذي يتعين القيام
به خلال الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله وان
تنفيذ ما تم التوافق عليه سيكون امرا
حاسما
من جهته رحب الممثل الخاص للاتحاد
الاوروبي للسلام في الشرق الاوسط
بتوصل اسرائيل والفلسطينيين الى تدابيرا
من اجل ارساء الاستقرار وقال كوكمانز على
تويتر انه يرحب بالانباء الوارده عن
اجتماع العقبه حيث اتفق وفدان اسرائيلي
وفلسطيني بمساعده من الاردن ومصر
والولايات المتحده على تدابير لتحقيق
الاستقرار في ضوء وضع اشد خطوره من اي وقت
مضى
كان اجتماع العقبه بين مسؤولين اسرائيليين
وفلسطينيين ومصريين وامريكيين قد اختتم
بالتاكيد على ضروره الالتزام بخفض التصعيد
على الارض ومنع المزيد من العنف كما اكد
المجتمعون على اهميه الحفاظ على الوضع
التاريخي في القدس دون تغيير كما اكدت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه والسلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه الاستعداد لوقف الاجراءات تلك
احاديه الجانب لمده ثلاثه الى سته اشهر
حيث يشمل ذلك التزاما اسرائيليا بوقف
مناقشه اقامه اي وحدات استيطانيه لمده
اربعه اشهر ووقف اي بؤر استيطانيه لمده
سته اشهر كما اتفق المشاركون على الاجتماع
مجددا في شرم الشيخ في شهر مارس المقبل
لتحقيق اهداف اجتماع العقبه
لكنها رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو على عكس ما تم التوافق عليه قال
ان البناء الاستيطاني في اراضي الضفه
الغربيه سيتواصل وفق الجداول المحدده وسبق
ان اشار مسؤول اسرائيلي في وقت سابق الى
انه لن يكون هناك تغيير على خططي بناء
تسعه الاف وخمسمائه وحده تيطانيه
في وقت سابق اعلنت هيئه الاسعاف
الاسرائيليه عن مقتل مستوطنين في عمليه
اطلاق نار جنوب نابلس وذكر مراسل العربيه
ان القوات الاسرائيليه اغلقت جميع الحواجز
في بلده حواره جنوب نابلس بحثا عن منفذي
الهجوم
[موسيقى]
شكلهم اثنين ميتين واحد بنازع واحد مات
[تصفيق]
هات حواره
ورا الش
سبي الله ونعم الوكيل فيكم
[موسيقى]
نزلوا على يا جماعه نزلوا على السهول
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه تدين الان هجمات مستوطنين على
بلده حواره بنابلس وحرق منازل المواطنين
وهذه الصور الاوليه التي تصلنا لهذه
المحاولات في حواره اذا بنابلس ولحرق
منازل المواطنين هناك وهذه ادانا الان في
الخبر العاجل من السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه لهذه الهجمات من المستوطنين
على بلده حواره بنابلس وطبعا كما ذكرنا
قبل قليل ياتي هذا بالتزامن
في نفس اليوم الذي اعلنت فيه هيئه الاسعاف
الاسرائيليه عن مقتل مستوطنين في عمليه
اطلاق نار جنوب نابلس قبل ذلك كان رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي قال بانه البناء
الاستيطاني في اراضي الضفه سيتواصل وفق
جداول المحدده وياتي كذلك بعد اجتماع
العقبه بين المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه ان الوزير
سامح شكري سيزور غدا العاصمه السوريه دمشق
في زياره هي الاولى لوزير خارجيه مصريه
لسوريا منذ 2011 كما اعلنت ان الزياره
ستشمل كذلك تركيا للاعراب عن التضامن بعد
كارثه الزلزال المدمر وعرض المساعده
هذا وقالت مصادر مصريه للعربيه ان القاهره
تعمل على اعاده ترتيب العلاقات مع الجانب
السوري وقد اتخذت قرارا بتوسيع العلاقات
مع سوريا بشكل اكبر وتدريجي واشارت الى ان
زياره وزير خارجيه مصر لدمشق تهدف الى
تنسيق التعاون في ملفات عده ابرزها الامن
وتحدثت المصادر عن ان القاهره سترسل وفودا
الى دمشق الفتره المقبله لتوسيع قاعده
زيارات بينهما واضافت المصادر ان القاهره
تحاول اقناع الولايات المتحده بتخفيف
العقوبات عن سوريا
كانت رئاسه سوريا قد اعلنت ان بشار الاسد
استقبل وفدا من الاتحاد البرلماني العربي
للتعبير عن التضامن مع دمشق بعد الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب البلاد مؤخرا واضافت
الرئاسه السوريه ان الوفد ضم رئيس الاتحاد
رئيس مجلس النواب العراقي محمد الحلبوسي
ورؤساء مجالس النواب في الامارات والاردن
وفلسطين وليبيا ومصر اضافه الى رؤساء وفدي
سلطنه عمان ولبنان والامين العام للاتحاد
البرلماني العربي
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا وزاره
الموارد المائيه في العراق تحذر امننا
المائي على المحن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اذا صحه الفلسطينيه
تتحدث عن مقتل شاب فلسطيني جرائها هجمات
المستوطنين على بلده حواره بجنوب نابلس
بلده في ولايه قهرمان مرعش كانت مركزا
للزلزال الاول الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا فكيف
كانت وكيف اصبحت بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من
الزلزال التفاصيل مع زيدان زنكلو
هنا في بلده بازار جوك بولايه كهرمان مرعش
في فجر السادس من فبراير وتحديدا عند
الساعه الرابعه وسبعه عشره دقيقه اهتزت
الارض نتيجه زلزال هو الاقوى والاشد
تدميرا في تاريخ تركيا الحديث
هذه البلده كانت مركز الزلزال الاول الذي
بلغت شدته سبع درجات فاصله ثمانيه اعشار
الدرجه على مقياس ريختر وبعمق 16 كيلومترا
بال قفص
دكتور شعرنا بالخوف كثيرا بدانا نفكر في
العالم الاخر خرجنا من المنزل وشاهدت
البناء الذي امامي قد ينهار مكثنا في
سياره جارنا لحين طلوع الصباح
كنت مستيقظا عند حدوث الزلزال وكان ابن
مستيقظا ايضا وعندما حدثت هذه الهزات
المدهشه في قوتها اختبانا تحت الابواب
للاحتماء هذا ما تعلمناه من تعليمات
الوقايه من الزلزال وبعد انتهاء الهزه
الاولى خرجنا من المنزل الذي كاد ينهار
وشاهدت بناء مكونا من اربعه طوابق انهار
بالكامل خلال جوله سريعه في البلده لاحظنا
ان العديد من اصحاب المحل التجاريه اعادوا
افتتاح محالهم اضافه الى بعض العائلات
التي تحاول افراغ محتويات منازلها رغم
التحذيرات الحكوميه ايضا تتواصل عمليات
ازاله الانقاض من المباني المدمره من بلده
بازارجيك بولايه كهرمان مرعش زيدان زنجلو
في تصريح اليوم مخزون المياه في البلاد
يقل عن ثمانيه مليارات متر مكعب ما يجعله
على المحك التصريح لوزاره الموارد المائيه
العراقيه التي اوضحت ان ما يرد من تركيا
وسوريا وايران اقل من 70% من مكان العراق
يتلقاه سابقا وكان من المفترض ان يسافر
وزير الموارد المائيه العراقيه الى تركيا
لمناقشه هذا الملف لكن تم تاجيل الزياره
لسبب كارثه الزلزال هناك
اليوم من كاليفورنيا للعاصفه الشتويه التي
ضربت جنوب الولايه وتسببت في انهيارات
طينيه على طول مسار نهر سانتا كلارا
انهيارات جرفت الاشجار وحتى عدد من البيوت
المتنقيه التي تستخدم للترفيح
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من المنوفيه
المصريه همه وتركيز لسيده تتعلم القراءه
والكتابه في اي سن في السابعه والثمانين
من عمرها
ولا سنه للعلم على امل ان تصل هذه الرساله
لكل المشاهدين في كل اقطار العالم شكرا
لمتابعتكم العربيه 360 وهذا صهيب معكم
الان يتابع في اخبار الساعه صهيب ماذا
لديك مساء الخير طاهر الخبر الساعه الوضع
يشتعل على ما يبدو في بلده حواره في نابلس
جنوب نابلس في الضفه الغربيه قتيل
الفلسطيني برصاص اسرائيل واكثر من 100
مصاب وهناك مستوطنون احرقوا العديد من
سيارات الفلسطينيين هناك نتابع الوضع بعد
قليل
[موسيقى]